bonsoir bruno bartocetti merci d'être
avec nous en direct sur rt france c'est
plutôt une bonne nouvelle bien
accueillie par la police sa décision du
conseil d'état
bonsoir et merci de m'avoir invité
la première à la première question est
ce qu'on doit faire confiance au juge
des référés qui finalement abonde dans
ce sens aujourd'hui on doit justement à
faire confiance à notre justice
et si celle ci se prononce favorablement
on peut en discuter mais on peut aussi
se montrer confiant vous savez ce soir
vous avez en face de vous un
syndicaliste mais aussi un policier
d'abord un policier ensuite un
syndicaliste et je crois que ce qui est
important c'est de ne pas être frileux
en matière de fichiers dès qu'on
prononce le mot fichier en france et on
peut comprendre mais sur notre notre
histoire notre histoire fait mal
lorsqu'on parle de fichiers mais est-ce
qu'aujourd'hui on travaille comme lors
du siècle dernier je ne crois pas je
crois qu'aujourd'hui les fichiers sont
faits pour être travaillés utilisé d'une
manière proportionnée et de manière
contrôlée
vous avez de nombreux fichiers qui sont
utilisés d'ailleurs ce qui est assez
surprenant en france c'est que dès qu'on
parle de fichiers de police on se
soulève contre ce phénomène là alors que
nous sommes fichier des centaines de
fois en france les banques les centres
commerciaux les réseaux sociaux nous
fiche de tout les côtés et la personne
ne réagit aussi aussi fortement
c'est ça qui est surprenant vous avez
entendu cet avocat tout à l'heure que
vient voir l'appartenance syndicale les
habitudes de vie avec effectivement la
sûreté de l'état
oui alors effectivement mais ça c'est
déjà d'actualité
je veux dire aujourd'hui par rapport à
ce texte par rapport à cette décision où
on a de nombreuses réactions mais mais
jusqu'à preuve du contraire on a
toujours travaillé justement sur sur
tout c'est sûr toutes ces thématiques
donc où il est très facile il est très
facile de continuer à travailler
justement sur sur quelque chose de 2
comment dirais-je de religieux ou de
syndicats il donne syndicalisme sur ce
thème c'est vraiment pas un problème
aujourd'hui on a on a quelque chose de
beaucoup plus carrés jeu parce que mieux
mieux ce sera abordée de manière
beaucoup plus contrôlés et tu seras
ajouté en propre dans le cadre de notre
travail ça doit pas être un problème ne
doit pas être parano par rapport à cette
décision là vous nous assurez enfin
c'est pas vous évidemment qu'elle est le
faire mais il n'ya pas quand même la
crainte que ces informations qui
relèvent du privé
finalement ce compost sur les réseaux
sociaux on n'a pas forcément envie que
les autorités voilà le con le consigne
ces informations vous pouvez nous les
rend type 2 ne seront pas utilisés entre
nous finalement écouté je vais vous
donner un exemple lorsqu'on a pu
travailler sur sur certains fichiers
dans la police pour pour pour remonter
sur les antécédents judiciaires d'une
personne ou suis remonté sur sur le
nombre de véhicules que vous pourriez
posséder il ya une vingtaine d'années
c'était très facile pour les policiers
de détergents et ses fichiers sans
contrôle aujourd'hui à partir du moment
où vous rentrez dans des fichiers de
police immédiatement vous devez
apparaître sur une procédure
donc nous sommes hyper contrôlé nous
pouvons pas sortir des données d'un
fichier sans s'expliquer et se justifier
justement notre travail
donc ça prouve bien qu'on a largement
évolué qu'on est très contrôlée et qu'on
ne peut pas pour des raisons autres que
de la sécurité intérieure ou sûreté
nationale
nous pouvons battre à travailler sur ces
fichiers donc il ya quand même une
protection des données sur ce que nous
n'avions pas encore il y avait une
tranche existe bien
c'est beaucoup plus facile pour
n'importe quel policier d'accéder aux
fichiers sans qu'on sache les raisons
pour lesquelles on rentrait dans ses
fichiers or aujourd'hui ce n'est plus le
cas donc je peux vous donner avec mon
expérience une garantie c'est que nous
travaillons pour la sécurité intérieure
certainement pas pour alimenter d'autres
sources en tout cas administratives ou
autres
par exemple pour bien qu'on comprenne
est ce que la police va se servir de ces
renseignements de ce fichier avant une
manifestation on se souvient évidemment
des manifestations le samedi dès gilet
jaune est ce que ces personnes seront
justement ficher la police va les
regarder un petit peu les profils des
personnes entre guillemets dits à risque
pour elle il a à partir du moment où il
ya un risque pour justement pour la
sécurité intérieure nous travaillerons
mais nous n'allons pas photographier
tous les manifestants de dents lors d'un
rassemblement pour les identifier et
hypothétiquement les cibles et comme d d
d extrémistes ce n'est pas du tout seul
but de ces fichiers c'est de pouvoir
justement aller plus vite et il ne pas
se tromper de cible
ça sera un outil il faut savoir que
voilà ces fichiers restaurant de ce sont
des outils se sont pas trompés eux qui
seront à la manoeuvre ce sont bien tous
les policiers qui travailleront avec
avec ces outils pour identifier des
fouteurs de trouble mais voilà il faut
savoir ce qu'on veut vous savez vous me
prenez l'exemple d'une manifestation
pour qu'elle soit préservée pour qu'elle
soit sécurisée
il faut écarter les fouteurs de trouble
c'est le but de deux de ces outils là
c'est de pouvoir faire la différence
entre les voiles ou les casseurs les
extrémistes et les manifestants
aujourd'hui clairement cet élargissement
c'est un vrai atout pour la police ça va
changer votre travail dans le bon sens
en tant que policier
disons que réglementairement ou oui
c'est un atout supplémentaire mais nous
avions déjà un autre possession ces
outils pour travailler c'est pour cette
raison que il n'y a aucune raison de
s'inquiéter aujourd'hui par rapport à un
texte qui est qui qui a été qui a été
finalement
accepter aujourd'hui sur ce thème il ya
aucune raison de s'inquiéter puisque
depuis depuis de nombreuses années nous
travaillons avec ces outils là et c'est
ça toujours été un atout à partir du
moment où on peut sécuriser justement
entre autres notre nation notre notre
population
c'est aux matières que sur un plan légal
on est encore plus q comment dirais-je
web beaucoup plus dans les clous et on a
des comptes à rendre à partie quand on
utilise ces fichiers mais on sera encore
plus dans une procédure pour pour faire
ressortir ce qu'on a ce qu'on doit
retenir c'est à dire ciblé identifier
ceux qui peuvent justement semer le
trouble sur notre territoire
quand je dis semer le trouble s'est pas
seulement sur des sur des idées sur des
idées bien précises des précise de ses
soucis qui peuvent aller très loin dans
le trouble et et porter une nuisance est
une atteinte à la liberté des uns et des
autres c'est ça qui est important
merci beaucoup bruno bartocetti d'avoir
été avec nous en direct sur rt france
merci à vous